okay today I'm going to talk to you
about investigating osmosis I'm going to
talk to you about a particular practical
you can do in order to find the
concentration of sucrose in a potato so
what we're going to do is if you
remember first of all as Moses the
movement of water particles from our
area of high concentration of water to
an area of low concentration of water
across a partially permeable membrane so
if you're unsure about that please watch
my other video about osmosis so first of
all I've can get a cork baura
now all this does is I can use this I
dig it into the potato and I can take
cylinders of potato out like this okay
so I'm going to end up with a few
different cylinders of potato now what I
need to do is before I do anything I
need to measure the mass of these
potatoes so I'm going to put them on an
electronic balance it's with only
electronic balance like that and I
measure the mass in grams okay now what
I'm then gonna do is I'm gonna have a
few different solutions each solution is
going to have a different concentration
of sucrose in so let's say here are my
four different beakers so all these
different potato cylinders from the same
potato everything else has kept the same
I want to use the same amount of liquid
the only thing that's different between
them is the percentage or the
concentration of sucrose so let's just
say this one has zero percent sucrose
that means it's pure water let's imagine
this one has 10 percent sucrose this one
has 20 percent sucrose and this one has
30 percent sucrose so I've just taken
all of those four different cylinders
and for each one first of all I measure
the mass and then I put them in the
solutions now what I do next is I leave
it need to leave this for at least 40
minutes because what's happening over
that forty minutes
is I could be having a change in mass if
the concentration of water is greater
outside the potato than it is inside the
potato there's going to be a net
movement of water in if if the
concentration of water is greater inside
than outside then it will move out so
we're looking to see the change in mass
is the potato gonna get lighter or less
mass or is it going to gain more mass as
water enters so let's imagine when I
measured the mass of each of these on
the electronic balance let's imagine
each of them weighed 10 10 grams so
here's my different concentrations of
sucrose as see just an some sucrose
concentration but in that much room -
right so initial mass let's say all of
them started off weighing 10 grams the
word initial just means at the beginning
so I'd leave these forty minutes and
then after I've left them 40 minutes I
take each one out I dry it off now it's
important to try it so I haven't got any
extra mass of water and then ivory
measured the mass using electronic
balance and let's say I got these
results here my final mass was 15 13 11
and 9 so this one increased in mass by 5
grams and this one decreased in mass by
one gram so first thing I need to do is
I need to find out the change in mass so
to do that you just do the final mass
take away the initial mass so this one
was 5 grams this one was 3 this one was
1 and careful of this one the change in
mass because it's gone down we're gonna
show it as minus 1 so what we need to do
now is we need to figure out the
percentage change in mass what percent
is it increased by or what percent is it
decreased by in order to do that we need
to use this calculation here we need to
do the change in mass divided by the
initial mass remember initial mass just
means the mass of the beginning and then
multiply it by 100 so for this one here
so the change in mass was 5 the initial
mass was 10
and then we multiply by 100 so this one
has increased by 50%
that's because because it's in pure
water the concentration of water is
greater outside and inside so the water
molecules have moved in increasing the
mass of the potato
next up use the same equation change in
mass which is 3 divided by my initial
mass then multiply by 100 so that one's
had a 30% change and I'm just going to
do these ones in my head or that one in
my head now this one please notice as
well the change in mass because it's
minus 1 we need to factor that in so
minus 1 divided by whoops minus 1/10 cuz
that's the initial mass multiplied by
100 so this one's has a minus 10%
it's got lighter the reason why this one
has a minus percent is because water
molecules have moved out of the potato
because the concentration of water
molecules is greater inside than outside
they are gonna move out okay so what do
we do next now just whatever thing we
could do is at the moment we don't know
the concentration of sucrose within this
potato so what we have to do is we
actually have to plot a graph so here's
what the graph would look like the
concentration of sucrose goes across
here this could be in percentage or it
could be given in moles of molarity and
the change in mass goes up here so
here's a positive change if the potato
increase the mass here's a negative
change in case it decreased in this so
let's just quickly see our results so at
0% 0% sucrose it is increased by 50%
mass at 10 percent sucrose it's 30 now
you'd be doing this on graph paper it's
just a photo doesn't show up
particularly well in here at 20 percent
sucrose there's been a 10% increase in
mass and at 30 percent concentration the
potato is actually decreased by 10
percent
so you've now got a graph now what you
can do is you could've draw a line of
best fit now mine is going to be perfect
because I haven't got graph paper but
there we go a line of best fit between
them now if you see this point here this
is really significant because this point
here would be the point at which the
potato didn't increase in mass and the
potato didn't decrease in mass that
means that the percentage that the water
concentration of sucrose was exactly the
same outside a potato than it is inside
the potato so there's no net movement of
water so that point there on our graph
shows us the concentration of sucrose in
the initial potato we've used our other
results to show the pattern at this
point here where there's no net movement
of water because our potato hasn't
gained mass or lost mass this must be
the concentration of sucrose in the
potato so we could see from here to
halfway between 20 and 30 so this one
here would have a 25% concentration of
sucrose in the potato so that is how we
investigate osmosis thank you